foreign
[Music]
hey everyone we are happy to continue to
provide you with the most exciting news
from Hollywood in the New Year 2023.
besides the departure of an actor from
Guardians of the Galaxy vol 3 we report
on the second season of House of the
Dragon a statement from Daniel Craig
about his successor as James Bond and
the started casting for the lead roles
of a gladiator sequel we also answer who
would win in a fight between horadol
Annabelle and her technical counterpart
Megan
the first James Bond movie was released
in 1962 and over the decades many
generations have been treated to a total
of 27 movies almost everyone knows at
least one movie from the franchise and
of course most Bond fans have their
favorite actor for the lead role Daniel
Craig played agent 007 for many years
but since the last movie no time to die
from 2021 it is clear that a new actor
Will slip into the world famous role in
the future there has been a lot of
speculation over the past year and a
couple of names have come up frequently
in countless discussions including Tom
Hiddleston Idris Elba Tom Hardy and even
The Witcher star Henry Cavill in an
interview with Josh Horowitz Daniel
Craig has now explicitly talked about
his successor in response to a question
from Horowitz about whether he had heard
of the rumors about Kick-Ass actor Aaron
Taylor-Johnson as James Bond the 54 year
old replied that he doesn't follow
rumors on social media while Craig's
answer was rather evasive he did not
deny the current rumor either and said
that he was looking forward to seeing a
new actor on the big screen prior to
this interview there were reports that
Taylor Johnson had already met with
producers Barbara Brockley and her
colleague Michael G Wilson the two are
said to have been very taken with Taylor
Johnson and there is no real evidence of
this yet after all the 32 year old will
also star in Craven the hunter is a
native writ and thus meets the most
essential requirement to be cast as
James Bond how much truth there is to
these reports remains to be seen in any
case there won't be a new movie before
2025 which is why those responsible can
still take their time with their
decisions
gladiator from the year 2000 is one of
the most popular historical films ever
especially the two main actors Joaquin
Phoenix and Russell Crowe gave the film
that special something thanks to their
performances which is why people have
been asking for a sequel for a long time
director Ridley Scott announced back in
2021 that the script for a continuation
had long been written meaning that
filming could likely start this year
casting for the main roles is currently
underway as the reliable site Puck news
reports the story in the original is
about the General Maximus who was
supposed to succeed the dying Emperor
Marcus Aurelius however aurelius's son
Commodus gets in the way and wants to
have Maximus and his family murder when
Maximus is eventually enslaved he finds
himself in the gladiatorial arena and
Bows revenge against kamadus as of yet
nothing is known about the plot of the
second part but a return of Russell
Crowe is unlikely following the death of
Maximus at the end of the first film
rumors have it that the sequel will
revolve around Spencer treat Clark's
character Lucius but this is also a mere
speculation we are looking forward to
further news who is your favorite to
play the lead role in which character
from the original would you like to
learn more about let us know in the
comments
Gerard Johnstone's horror film Megan
just hit theaters on January 6th the
content is about a killer doll developed
by scientist Gemma with artificial
intelligence in order to help her niece
the latter has only recently become an
orphan and is supposed to form an
emotional bond with the doll needless to
say the idea backfires and Megan
develops far too strong of a protective
Instinct torture Protege which
eventually results in deaths in late
December Entertainment Weekly wondered
what a clash between Megan and another
creepy doll could look like the talk is
of Annabelle who first appeared in
director James Wan's 2013 horror film
The Conjuring Juan Jason Blum Gerard
Johnstone and Allison Williams who stars
in Megan provide the answers both
Williams and Juan wouldn't bet against
Megan because as an artificial
intelligence it likely has some aces up
its sleeve director Gerard Johnstone on
the other hand would rather put his
money on Annabelle since she is a demon
which also matches the opinion of horror
producer Jason another obvious battle is
much easier to predict Megan vs Chucky
the murdered all Chucky from the cult
franchise probably wouldn't stand a
chance against Megan well I'm emphasized
in conclusion obviously Megan should not
be underestimated and we are eager to
find out how the finished movie will be
received by the audience
the prequel series House of the Dragon
which takes place almost 200 years
before the events of Game of Thrones
will be continued with a new season in
the near future information about the
second season has been scarce however
House of the Dragon writer and producer
Sarah Hess has now spoken to the U.S
magazine variety about the plans of
those in charge for the first time
especially those who know the extensive
book series by George R.R Martin will be
familiar with blood and cheese as the
storyline is one of the most gruesome
and as the name suggests bloodiest
moments in the Game of Thrones universe
as Hess confirms the finale of the
storyline will also be the finale of the
second season and thus comparable to the
Red Wedding from Game of Thrones season
3 will be a violent way to kick off the
waiting period until the next season in
terms of plot the story revolves around
the two assassins blood and cheese after
a significant death in season 1 which
also triggers the infamous War called
Dance of the Dragons the two are hired
by the blacks to take revenge the target
of the two Allison hightower's son who
was set to ascend the throne from now on
since the two are extremely skilled
Killers anyone on their list is almost
certain to die peth stresses that fans
of the original will not be disappointed
and that they are currently working on
the final touches of the season finale
filming on season 2 of House of the
Dragon will begin this March and the
premiere is scheduled for 2024 on HBO
events
at the end of November the Guardians of
the Galaxy holiday special was released
on Disney plus just in time for
Christmas the nearly 45 minute film
includes a special appearance by U.S
actor Kevin Bacon as well as almost all
of the important characters in the film
series as we now know this was the
penultimate MCU film overall for xwwe
Star Dave Batista who plays Drax he
disclosed this in an interview with GQ
where he was very grateful for his
participation in the Guardians of the
Galaxy franchise and at the same time
revealed how exhausting the makeup
procedure had been every time besides
Batista is not getting any younger and
in his mid-50s it is becoming
increasingly difficult to stay as fit as
he needs to be for the role of drags he
wants to devote himself to more serious
roles in the future saying he loved
playing tracks but doesn't want to make
that role his legacy in doing so he
differs from his former WWE colleague
Dwayne Johnson who plays rather
unidimensional roles and is so
successful with them that he was
temporarily the high highest paid
Hollywood star ever in the future we
will see more of Batista in roles such
as glossu Rabon and dune or Duke Cody in
the recently released Glass Onion a
Knives Out mystery Batista by the way is
not the only one to say goodbye to the
MCU after Guardians of the Galaxy Vol 3.
as as already suspected some Guardians
will die on screen in the upcoming film
thus Paving the way for the respective
actors to move on to other projects in
addition the movie will also be the last
MCU feature from director James Gunn who
has been head of DC Studios since
November unrelated to Batista's
interview a new image was recently
released showing some characters you can
see Dave Batista as Drax Palm Clement
tf's mantis Chris Pratt's Star-Lord and
Karen gillen's nebula what makes it
special are the Guardians new uniforms
which since the events of the holiday
special serve a specific purpose and
happen to look pretty cool by the way
don't miss the first trailer for
Guardians of the Galaxy vol 3 on our
Channel theatrical release is scheduled
for May 5th 2023.
these were all the first news of the
year if you want to know how the MCU and
dceu will continue in the next few years
we recommend our preview of all upcoming
superhero movies we look forward to
continue bringing you the best news
every week
[Music]